A list of the most influential people of all time
wouldn't be complete without Sir Isaac Newton.
Newton's laws are tied to almost everything we
see in everyday life. They help us understand how
cars work, how baseballs move, how anything moves.
Yet there was a secret side to the 17th century
scientist which will become clear by the end
of this story. By his mid-20s, Newton had already
invented calculus. Not bad for the son of an
illiterate farmer. He would never meet his father
who died three months before his birth on
Christmas day 1642 in the small english village
of Woolsthorpe Manor in the county of Lincolnshire.
He was a premature baby and so small he was later
told he could fit inside a quart mug. He barely
survived. When Newton was three, his mom remarried
and moved to a nearby village to live with a
wealthy clergyman. Newton was left behind in the
care of his grandparents. That abandonment scarred
him. Years later, he wrote a list of his sins,
recalling an outburst from childhood: "Threatening
my father and mother Smith to burn them and the
house over them." He was a curious child - more
interested in mechanics than making friends.
He carved this sundial as a nine-year-old. When
he was 12, he enrolled at a local grammar school/
His signature can still be seen by a
windowsill of the King's School today.
After the death of his stepdad, his mother
tried to remove him from school so he could
be a farmer - a prospect that he dreaded. Luckily,
the schoolmaster convinced his mother to send
him back to class where he gained the knowledge
necessary to enter the University of Cambridge
in 1661, paying his way by working as a valet.
Although he studied the works of the ancient
Greek philosophers, he questioned their
theories writing in his notebook in Latin,
"Plato is my friend, Aristotle is my friend, but
my best friend is truth." He vowed to find the
truth through rigorous scientific experimentation.
His time as an undergrad was unremarkable but the
extraordinary circumstances that happened next
would set the stage for his greatest achievements.
Shortly after receiving his Bachelor's degree
in 1665, the bubonic plague ravaged Europe and
would take the lives of an estimated
one out of every four people in London.
The pandemic forced Newton to work from
his childhood home for the next two years
and would lead to his most amazing breakthroughs.
He used a prism to discover that white light
and sunlight is made up of
the colors of the rainbow.
The widely held belief at the time was Aristotle's
theory that color was a mix of black and white.
To prove his theory, Newton built a reflecting
telescope that used mirrors rather than lenses -
leading to a more accurate image. That's a whole
lot safer than the time he stuck a sewing needle
into his eye socket to figure out if altering his
eye shape would change his perception of color.
Outside the family home was also an apple tree. The
famous apple tree. Legend has it that Newton was
sitting beneath a tree when an apple bonked him on
the head, prompting him to think about gravity - the
force that brings things down. There's no evidence
to suggest the fruit actually fell on his head
but he did ask the question that helped unlock our
understanding of the universe: Could the same force
reach all the way to the moon? He reasoned that
the same gravitational pull kept the moon orbiting
around Earth rather than wandering off and he
believed this could also explain the movement of
our planets in the solar system. The mathematics at
the time wasn't sophisticated enough to determine
the motion of these objects so Newton invented
his own form of math calculus. There was a dispute
over who actually invented calculus. When German
mathematician Gottfried Leibniz published his
paper on calculus in 1684, Newton claimed he'd
done the same work 20 years earlier. The thing
is, Newton was so secretive that he hadn't actually
made his efforts public because he couldn't stand
the scrutiny of his work. When Leibniz appealed
to the Royal Society in London, Newton wielded his
influence as the scientific academy's president to
get it to side with him. Most historians agree that
the two discovered calculus independently. In 1667,
after the end of the plague, he returned to the
University to continue his research as a fellow.
He was a workaholic. Sometimes, he'd forget to eat.
Just two years later while still in his mid-twenties,
he obtained one of the most prestigious academic
posts in the world. The Lucasian Professor
of Mathematics later held by none other
then Stephen Hawking. Yet he was indifferent to his
students. One time, when no one showed up for class,
he is said to have lectured to an empty room. His
true passion lay in research. In 1687, he published
his masterpiece: the Mathematical Principles of
Natural Philosophy - often referred to simply as
Principia - one of the most important works ever
written. This was his own first edition copy.
It was here that he laid out his law of universal
gravitation as well as his three laws of motion.
The first describes how an object acts when no
force is acting upon it. For example, a rocket stays
still until a force is applied to it. The second
law tells us that the more mass an object has,
the more force it'll take to move it. A larger
rocket requires more fuel to make it accelerate.
The final law states that for every action there
is a reaction. The engine produces hot exhaust
gases that flow through the rear of the rocket. In
reaction, a thrusting force is produced - pushing the
rocket skywards. Newton may be considered one of
the greatest scientists the world has ever known
yet he actually contributed more words to theology.
Newton believed the Bible provided the code to the
natural world and by carefully studying the Holy
texts, he could predict the future. He believed the
apocalypse would happen in the year 2060 with the
caveat: "It may end later but I see no reason for
its ending sooner." He foresaw a period marked by
war and catastrophe followed by the second coming
of Christ and the beginning of a new, divine era. His
religious side was largely hidden from the public
all the way until 1936, when Sotheby's auctioned
off his theological manuscripts. They ended up in
the hands of a Jewish scholar before being given
to the state of Israel. 7,500 pages in Newton's
own handwriting. He did hold unorthodox views of
Christianity by rejecting the Trinity - the belief
in the father, son, and the holy spirit. And also
fought against the attempt by King James II to
catholicize the universities which got him elected
as a Member of Parliament where he served two
brief terms. Apparently, the only thing he said on
the record was to request that a window be closed.
Newton also had another unknown side to him. He
spent 25 years secretly studying alchemy - the
search for a method to turn common metals into
gold. This is a manuscript where Newton wrote
down a recipe thought to be a step toward
concocting the mythical Philosopher's Stone
now popularized in the Harry Potter series.
Alchemists believed it could even help humans
achieve immortality. Unfortunately, Newton may have
gotten mercury poisoning from all the time spent
in the laboratory. Examinations of his hair after
his death found high levels of the toxic compound
which scholars believe could explain his mental
breakdown in 1693 when he lost grip on reality.
He wrote letters accusing the few friends he
had of conspiring against him. He suffered from
insomnia and oppression. The personal crisis
lasted a year and a half. Not too long after he
ended his 30-year career at Cambridge. In 1696,
he moved to lLndon to help run the Royal Mint.
Britain's finances were in ruins because of the
rampant practice of clipping off pieces of coins.
Counterfeiting was also an issue. Newton used a
scientific precision to improve the accuracy of
coinmaking as Warden and then Master of the Mint.
He also took it upon himself to prosecute culprits,
some of whom ended up hanging from the gallows. His
later years would be spent further cementing his
reputation and sometimes that meant trying
to erase his rivals from the history books.
Another ugly dispute involved a brilliant
scientist named Robert Hooke who contended
he was the one who gave Newton the notion that
led to his theory of gravity and wanted credit.
In response, Newton is accused of using his
powers as President of the Royal Society
to get rid of the only known portrait of Hooke.
None exists to this day. Newton succeeded in
getting the legacy he wanted. In 1705, Queen Anne
of England knighted him during a royal visit to
the University of Cambridge, making him Sir Isaac
Newton. A complicated man who remained reclusive
yet desperately wanted to be remembered. Who threw
himself into his work at the cost of all hobbies
and never married. Who was a man of science and
also, a man of faith. Newton died in his sleep on
March 20, 1727 and was buried at Westminster Abbey.
the Latin inscription on his grave reads: Here
lies that which was mortal of Isaac Newton. His
immortal legacy continues to mold our modern world.
The English poet Alexander Pope was so moved
by Newton's accomplishments, he wrote the famous
epitaph: Nature and nature's laws lay hidin
night. God said "Let Newton be" and all was light.
For Newsthink, I'm Cindy Pom.